leute wir hören nichts gerade
angesprochen privatgesprächen und
deshalb rede ich es lange was uns muss
ich das ganz aufwendig er zensieren und
der fans möchte bestimmt nicht dass ich
hier sei geschwächt
was geht hier ist euer kran ii und heute
spiele ich mit dem liebenswerten sex mit
- ein lucky blog wars ii auf castilla
und also wirklich fand später zum ersten
mal
pass bloß auf dass du nicht irgendwie
diesen hunger oder so was kriegst du
dann explodiert und sag ich dir sagen
dass man geld passiert ist was denn ich
hasse alle kisten abgebaut diese
bereiche oder eine zu öffnen ich die
dritte explodierender lösen weg mehr
oder ein bisschen immer kisten
rausgekommen bei dir ja wo sie aber
glück eigentlich also hat die letzte
explodiert der letzte die letzten
besucher kommt manchmal kommt wie
melonen explodieren nicht dass ein so
schwerer kanal länger hierarchie blogs
können
naja ich hab paar fliegende schweine und
sowas bekommen aber ja ich denke mir
wirklich in letzter zeit immer öfter so
jo euro in der mitte ok nummer eins
fällen das gleiche
und da sehen wir auch in runde zwei los
geht's vielleicht habe ich diesmal
bisschen mehr glück
ich nehme jetzt einfach jede runde die
ich hier spiele weil lucky blog wars
kann ziemlich nervtötend sein wenn man
es aufnehmen will
ich weiß nicht ob du das weißt ja ich
bin zum ersten mal hier irgendwelche
super shooter findet es gut aber der hat
nur fünf schüsse oder sowas
ich habe zwei stück direkt davon kriegt
ja also man muss wirklich sagen das
spiel ist ist nicht so krass skill
basiert ja aber man kann kann wirklich
eine menge spaß haben sagt ja wenn ich
jetzt gerade mehr zum rating veranlagt
gewesen wäre
aber es auch wirklich mal
sowohl kommt der rente ok nach die gäste
kicker folglich ist direkt oder wie
wenig optimistisch ich habe endlich
konnte er über das team
ich weiß nur wenn das darf aber in
holsterfeld gesagt ich würde aber ganz
schnell in die mitte gehen mit meinen
ändert wenn ich du wäre ganz schön in
die mitte werden weil nämlich intakt
nach der mitte gibt es halt nicht so
viele erstmal zu dir
ich bin okay werfen die mitte
aber wenn ich runtergefallen bin ich
direkt draußen oder ja aber ja ich hab's
geschafft ich habe aber nicht mehr so
viele herzen alternativ viele teile ich
muss aber aufpassen
du musst auch aufpassen kann auch
explodieren die kiste was herauskommen
möchte er ist jemand in der mit hohem
tempo unter tel ja der hatten harnisch
auftakt aber ich klatsche nicht am bogen
jan knopf weg war dass du den lucky
boden muss ja keine ahnung hab ich hab
ja lucky boy hab ich halte deshalb ja
der spielmodus ist relativ immer kommt
wir können mit lucky boxen der mit einer
mega angst weil ich allein an der person
kann
doch ich habe irgendwo ist hammelfleisch
sowie wenn die zombie das mal klatscht
und physik studiert und abgeschlossen
ich habe mich war die deb kann ja auch
explodieren also war das hat explodiert
sie alles ist das ist so ein scheiß
chaos queen abba zombie egal was die da
unten vergangen hat mir erklärt der
kanton die fast alter was ist hier los
ich habe weiterhin der andere herz
richtig habe ich habe
oh gott sie zum beispiel kommt was auf
passaus pass auf ich habe was ich sagen
wollte ich habe einen golden apple er
den will ich auch okay wartet die lachen
als erstmal uhr aber ich merke gerade
auch wenn ich wenn ich mit diesen
scharfen irgendwas schieße dann sterben
die direkt nicht fleisch wenn wir jetzt
gingen zum zombie stellen sind ja auch
aus wir sind immer raus dann meist ganz
kurz und scharf zu mir also die sind so
viele gegner
irgendwelche skelette mit sich schießen
müssen mit dem einem neubau macht ein
bisschen klatten und die anderen die
anderen mitspieler chillen der nächste
er kommt jemand jetzt kommt ihr neues
kommt auch vom gegenspieler ich fertig
war zurücklegt verdammt okay
pauli da kommt richtig viele jetzt in
die mitte kimi ich weiß nur dass ich
schießen glaube ich mit dem lucky wo das
heißt für mich rennen
ja ob dieser mini hat mich um haare
gekriegt poker der typ hat in lucky boy
ich habe auch den lucky boy aber ich
habe mir die pfeile nicht aufgehoben
die fähigkeit ihr töten ja ich hab ihn
ich hab ihn perfekt fand sie bestimmt in
youtube herzlich
das ist nicht immer so bei dem blut aber
guck mal wie op dieser zombie ist der
einfachen verzaubertes der
schwerindustrie droppen
das wäre megacool meine mental ist es
auch voll aber ich könnte diese und
tatsächlich gewinnen ist er unglaublich
brauche ich nicht brauche ich nicht
gerne so ist es so so klassisch wenn man
mit franz auf nimmt er irgendwie ist er
dann immer weg wer holt sich in diesem
neuen blöcke ins inventar series b und
warum sich das geradezu behindert ich
glaube das habe ich alles durch die
jungs
rom hatten capes wird leider nicht so
viel auf aber ich habe noch einen
gegenspieler jetzt auch halb so wild
lol es sei deshalb aus der welt gefallen
ist und hab ich grad die runde gewonnen
stark okay dann sehen wir uns gleich
nochmal besser der franz winter probleme
ich weiß nicht aber wahrscheinlich räder
nur unter sehen jetzt gleich nächsten
runde wieder da sehen wir wieder meine
freunde und der franz ist auch wieder
mit dabei
was war los meine mama ich gefragt was
sie kochen hat war natürlich priorität
müsse ich bin komplett egal
foto oh gott ich habe villiger gekriegt
mir dachte bei dem keine sachen kaufen
da ist die luft für udo wenn wir nur
oder im chat steht das heißt brennen
ich habe jetzt in gold april ist gut das
ist sehr gut aber ich hoffe die methoden
abbauen ist verstehe ich diese
superbauten krieg geworden damit ich
habe angst gekriegt sagt feige verdammt
aber ich habe mir änderte dann kann ich
es schaffen
ich möchte aber nicht in die mitte
pforten wieso die ringe sind kannst du
einfach reinfallen klare der bombardiert
mich hier gerade dick mit seinem bogen
ja und dann solch eine gier applikation
gerding in eine ähnliche lage probiere
mich oben entlang irgendwie zu bauen wo
mich vielleicht nicht sieht und dann
werde ich in die mitte die letzten meter
mit der enter vergehen ich denke dass
irgendwas liegt muss irgend so ein bett
zu bauen lassen
das werde ich auch weil alle leute
spielen nur noch groß also deshalb macht
ihr auch mal so was anderes für mich
irgendwie selbst in den himmel loben
aber ich finde es halt irgendwie krass
also wirklich ich habe mir so für
inspiration was sie heute aufnehmen kann
ich hab' ich sollte mich auf anderen
stellen als umgeschaut
und da wirklich fast jeder poor's
aufgenommen
das und irgendwie o&o stirbst du oh mein
gott ich habe ein halbes herzig war
glaube ich noch nie so knapp in meinem
leben trotzdem galt ab in die mitte wo
es der kripo ich dachte das wäre lag und
der werdet ihr mich gekriegt oder so
also ehrlich wer kann paul ist ja okay
war knapp die richtig krass jetzt krieg
ich runter ich länger um wieder nach
oben und dann finde ich wieder runter
seltsamen teleport player was gibt's
hier tut ihm ein stetiger teleport team
member als ob ich brauche ja man kann
sich vielmehr wahrscheinlich aus wie
eines teams doch erlaubt aber man muss
ja irgendwie sind team member suchen
oder so dass ich weiß wie das läuft
läuft diese kisten philippinen ziemlich
chrysler allerdings kosten durch
geringste geblockt aber ich habe jetzt
in la kibo und des lackes ort das ist
verdammt gut
das ist dafür ein tyrann und will ja
keinem schwein auch keine ahnung wie
heißen die teile motors in der steinzeit
nehme ich meine die gans zur römischen
zeiten wie heißen die kleinen genau
wieso ich weiß nicht wie ihr traum nicht
klar die autorin sondern so komische
teile sachsen oder so ich weiß nicht
ich weiß auch nicht was du meinst
ehrlich gesagt sie also nasenring das
richtige ochsen stier 801 minuten genau
was sie mal nicht die sehen sie müssen
weiter ich habe so gutes zeug
sieht so ein bisschen web wenn die map
von oben sieht sie müssen nach tribute
von panem zwei aus oder bestimmter teil
ich weiß nicht aber in diesem dschungel
sind verkürzt dass die leute wir hören
nichts gerade wieder an dinge gesprochen
privatgesprächen und deshalb rede ich
erst lange weil sonst muss ich das ganz
aufwendig zensieren und der fans möchte
bestimmt nicht dass ich hier sage nein
das ist glaube ich leute ist es
schwierig mit dem franz aufzunehmen kann
ich nur sagen eine selbst youtuber seit
fragt nicht - zu verordnen kann
so haben wir jetzt wirklich habe erzählt
ich glaube den verzicht weil er mietet
sich sonst immer und es hat das
vergessen jetzt können wir herausfinden
was er so treibt wenn wir schon mal
immer man wollten ein oder andere von
euch das nicht
nein weil ich wirklich nicht gemietet
ach so ja wir haben einen schrecklichen
gespräche aufgenommen
ok neuesten hab ich gesehen weil die
nächsten gerichtskasse rüsten
umso mehr muss ich ihn kriegen als er
tanzt richtig vor mir fast egal ob beck
in den kader ist durch kickback doch
eigentlich schon bei kindern gern noch
beck ok dann gucken wahrscheinlich doch
kein ok aber okay ich schieße jetzt
einfach so richtig leckeres castro nein
bei mir nicht der per 3 bar oder so er
lag von mir ich dachte okay
der tod ist gleich weg der der macht
nicht mehr lange von ihm habe ich auch
noch das lakies ort und dann dann habe
ich echt ok alter wie ich hier einfach
dieser spielmodus es so krass es richtig
verwöhnt
jetzt stell dich ja der in harnisch hat
sich einen bunten bogen und war als
krasser hätte ich nicht gedacht
dabei der letzte ist wie sauna jani
schreibt werdet hier und das
amerikanische anti amerikanischen ok
dann sehen was beim nächsten mal ich
habe es euch gefallen und bist ein motto